for you here's my question
for you with bezos um
how ambitious you think he is meaning do
you think
he has ambitious above being the richest
man in the world
yes you think so yes and what would that
be what do you think his ambitions are
you think he wants to run one day you
think he wants to be a president
i don't think so the the rockefeller i
think the ultratech wealthy
now i really honestly believe that their
ambition is to try to live forever
that's it
i think that they want to live forever
what does that have to do with imposing
anything on you
you need the resources you need as much
money as possible i get that that's
totally fine with me but what does that
got to do with hurting somebody else if
you want to live forever let's just say
that's your ambition
everybody has different ambitions and
fantasies listen if we all find out
everyone's fantasies
you'd probably unfriend eighty percent
of your people that you're friends with
right
ricky wouldn't sit next to me on high
five if if eighty percent
you gotta dab up gerard that was high
five but the point is
so what's wrong with his fantasy wanting
to live forever if that's what nothing
what else do you think is his ambitions
do you think that's what it is you think
he has
aspirations of the new world order
because i want to have so much money
it seems to me that all these ultra
billionaires the elon musk now the bezos
even
uh richard branson it's otherworldly
stuff
it's like you've already dominated on
earth congratulations you're worth 100
billion gazillion dollars
what's up mars what's up moon what's up
next you know he's planting my flag of
amazon on the moon
have you guys heard about the 48 million
dollar 10 000 year clock he built
that he's building right now he put 48
million dollars
can you pull up the article here so this
guy built a 48 million dollar clock
called the 10 000 hour 10 000 year
clock he's building it to bury it in a
mountain
i don't know if you guys have heard
about this or not he's building it 42
million
click on it ten thousand year clock okay
jeff bezos was building a ten thousand
year clock inside a mountain go up so we
can see the pictures
uh what does that mean at ten thousand
years well he okay so
go go a little lower so i can read this
so okay engineers and contracts are
building a massive multi-room clock
inside a mountain in west texas a clock
that will tell time
for the next 10 000 years and despite an
informal website with a whiff of
block spa this is jeff bezos project
there are a lot of surprises in the
story of clock of long
normal so who first imagined a 10 000
year clock in 1986 he's visiting
professor at mit et cetera et cetera so
if you go up a little bit
his idea with this clock when they ask
him why are you doing this he says
long-term thinking i'm a long-term
thinker so he's building
a clock that's going to outlast
how many generations 10 000 years and
he's going to bury it
apparently in this mountain in texas
i don't even know which mountain because
texas doesn't happen but this has a
mountain over here this is where he's
going to plug
spirits into the ai here's here's here's
the thing with a guy like this to me
okay
couple things with a guy like this to me
number one um
you know one he's gonna get targeted
because you have a lot of money two
i think he's a terrible communicator i
think he's a terrible communicator
who the hell was his publicist or his pr
rep
that approved the script for him to say
i want to thank all my employees and
customers for paying for this dude
who the hell wrote that script for you
go
hire a writer for you to teach you how
to write a damn script
to say hey employees thank you so much
for working so hard you paid for this
i'd like to thank all the little ants
down beneath me
by the way it's almost as if you are
giving people the opportunity to trash
you
so number one i think he's a terrible
communicator number one
he's a terrible communicator i don't
think he's a good communicator number
two
i think he brings some of the stuff upon
himself because
uh uh you know a lot of these
billionaires like i remember one time i
said with mike ditka
i'm in chicago i'm interviewing him it's
probably one of the
least viewed interviews out there
because it's not the mike ditka that you
and i remember
where he says here's a coin buddy call
somebody who cares you know and he goes
back and forth with the media
and you know all this stuff i sat down
with the interview and he was so
apologetic
you know i probably shouldn't have done
it that way i probably shouldn't have
done it this way
i probably shouldn't have done it that
way and i'm sitting i'm like why are you
apologizing
you killed it you're an all-time you
know you created a position tied in
you know you went out there and you won
as a player you want to say you went as
a coach are you kidding me you're like a
ultimate badass of a man stay in your
position with who you are right
you're you're getting so much pressure
from media where some of these guys are
constantly feeling like they have to
apologize
you're the richest man in the world
you've created 1.2 1.3 million jobs
worldwide he is worth 200 let's just say
he's worth 250 billion dollars
between him and his ex-wife and the
amount of money she gave away put the
two together he's about worth about a
quarter of a billion dollars
he owns 16 of amazon let me say this one
more time 16
that's 51 not 60 he's only a 16
owner of amazon amazon right now is
worth what 1.8
trillion dollars right say it's a two
trillion dollar company
if he's worth 16 it's what 320
if you take 300 trillion dollars out of
the 300 billion dollars out of 1.5
trillion it's what
1.5 trillion dollars you did this math
before right you know
right now he i just did it right now but
this is basic stuff guys this is not
competitive
here's the point the point is this this
man has created
1.5 trillion dollars for others yes
let me say this he's made 1.5 trillion
dollars
for others you don't think he exploits
his employees you know
let me let me go to that argument let me
go to that argument there so let's talk
about exploiting your employees
have a hard time understanding
exploiting your employees here's why let
me explain to you why
um so you're exploiting your employees
in 2021 in 2021 with dei
with all this stuff that's going on you
cannot do that today
exploiting your employees in 2021 with
instagram with snapchat with tick tock
with facebook with live
is mathematically impossible and not
only that i have your phone
and not only that it's absolutely dumb
okay for you to be able to do something
like that let me continue a little bit
more with this
why here's why first of all back in the
days you know ford got a lot of heat for
people who work for yeah right and they
would say you're making people because
if you look at the stats kai i don't
know if you have these stats or not you
know back in the days and
in 1889 the average amount of hours the
average worker number
in america worth 69 hours a week yeah in
89 in 18 1889
in the 1920s 1930s that numbers were
still in the 60s
like 63 to 65 hours a week the average
employee is working
63 to 65 hours a week in what year and
we're talking 2030s right that's because
of who
ford ford was the biggest employer they
just employed yeah
18 30. 69 hours you're seeing the
numbers and it's
coming down to like you know there goes
like 50 hours
all this stuff right and then if you
look at when the nine to five thing came
about
everything dropped below 40. you see
that number right there around 1934
39.2 hours 38.7 hours so that was
because of ford they came out with this
idea to say you cannot get people to
work this many hours
union and 401 back in fortnite negotiate
and the guys are like listen if i'm
going to give you 30 years of my life
you got to give me some kind of a
pension
for the greet boom that's how pension
plan came about yeah i'll work for you
you give me a pension plan right this is
in
during that time so okay great today
you don't like how hard my amazon's
working you go guess what
quit if it sucks we have vanessa right
here she quit she didn't like it she's
great more power to you she's here what
was it like working for amazon vanessa
honestly yeah no it sucked um in my
opinion
i feel like they pay you shouldn't be 16
it should be at least 20
for the amount of packages that we move
around but
yeah if you have another option to leave
leave is it true
is it true that you don't get bathroom
breaks and stuff like that it's very
hard like if
you you technically do but you can feel
the pressure for sure of like
if you go like all eyes from the
managers aren't you and it's not
comfortable
uh and what you said about the phones
yeah you cannot have your phone on you
that that i know that's true
yeah and by the way here's the other
part like the question about that
okay so you know how many people today
how many people today come out of
college like one of the things reid
hastings talks about the founder of
uh uh not founder he's one of the guys
mark is the founder but he's one of the
guys at the beginning netflix ceo right
he's the guy that helped the company be
worth a couple hundred million by the
way
they lost 423 000 subscribers last uh i
don't know if you saw that
post pandemic we'll talk about that
here's one of the things he said they
had a meeting one time
read hastings they're sitting there and
i said you know what was the best
feeling about netflix
everybody's like what he says it felt so
good that people finally wanted to work
that netflix
just to put it on their resume that i
worked at netflix
he says that's when we knew we made it
you know how many people want to work on
amazon to put it on their resume
seriously
no no no i disagree you think people
want to put that on their resume like
it's like something
yes they do yes they do people want to
put in their resume that they worked at
jp morgan that they worked at goldman
that they worked at
facebook that they worked at these
places because they're in that world
with amazon him
talking about how much he's making
people work similar stories with what
sam walton went don't work there
leave don't work in an environment like
that nobody honest
i'm shocked that you're taking this
you're notorious for treating your
employees well you go above and beyond
for your money
you're not here what i'm saying to you
is if i mistreat you
leave i don't deserve you gerard you
were with us before yeah okay you
because of a personal relationship you
went back to what
new york and you and i had a
conversation one of the most eloquent
emails ever written was written by you
okay when you left you left i said i
like this guy
you left where are you right now back
here why are you here
well you look but the point is but if
how do i treat you
very very well would you be here if i
treated you like no
so but but you left you went and saw the
market then you're back
if bezos treats people so bad then leave
we are not forcing anybody to work over
there now let me give you the negative
side
of why i think he gets a black guy
here's why i think he gets a black guy
so i think the problem is the following
i think if
you play politics when it favors you
on a party and you don't when it doesn't
favor you that's when you create enemies
meaning hey i'll go team up with these
guys if this is going to favor my
company but i'm not going to team up
with these guys if this doesn't favor my
company so you become a flip-flopper or
you become somebody that can't take a
stand for certain positions that you got
fastest way to create enemies take a
stand make a stand what you believe in
if you do that you're gonna have a
problem with that
but bezos right now sometimes people
don't know where he really stands do you
stand with the guys that say i'm not
going to pay that much taxes
do you stand with the people that's like
hey let's take care of the employees
where are you standing
with jeff bezos do you stand with bernie
sanders do you stand with uh trump do
you stand with bite and who do you stand
with what's wrong with playing both
sides though
if you're a businessman i i think as a
businessman no no it's nothing's wrong
with that but you're going to be a
target
that's all you're going to be a target
if you pick one side anyway then no but
you're
if you're saying i'm all progressive i'm
not like let me put it's going to come
at you let me put it to you this way i
may not like
aoc but i respect aoc i mean i like her
policies i got a lot of respect for aoc
you have no idea how much i respect
bernie sanders i respect sanders because
he takes a stand here's his position
this is what he believes in yeah you
mean to me sanders sanders when he ran
i was flabbergasted when he
when he threw into town and says i'm
just going to go support buy it i was
flabbergasted because
head-to-head debate sanders against
biden sanders will destroy
biden in a debate it's not even close
because he believes in what he's talking
about destroying hillary and then they
submarined him
that's and that they did that twice by
the way they did that twice by the which
means even democrats don't want
socialism to be in america which is just
can you say that one more time
even democrats don't want socialism
no no no first of all first of all let's
face it here let me ask you a question
you think
obama right now is a capitalist or
socialist capitalist question for you
when he started as a president you think
he was more socialist or capitalist i
think
i think the woke left has made democrats
be like what is going on
hang on let me ask you the question one
more time when obama first ran do you
think he was more a socialist or
capitalist
more socialist definitely more i'm
asking him yeah i'm asking i think
there's a mixture of both i don't i i i
don't i don't think he was full
socialism i don't it's a basic
question do you think he was a little
bit further left than he is
now tell me why i think like
anyone uh you have to evolve
and change i don't think that's what it
is and and
i just think when you start realizing
you're paying taxes and the money's
being used for nothing you start kind of
questioning and saying what the hell you
guys doing my taxes yeah
i think that needs to be a little bit
lower the more you create commerce
and you're doing your part that's above
and beyond your peers you start
questioning a little bit what so you
start off with this concept of socialism
being noble
until you compete in the marketplace
saying like wait a minute man i'm doing
a lot more than the other guys doing
why see no that's not fair so eventually
you become a capitalist so eventually
like yeah i'm not a socialist i'm a
capitalist
obama today is a capitalist he ain't no
socialism just everybody's a million
dollars to speak at goldman for an hour
yeah
he ain't no he ain't nobody is bad so
going back to it look i don't know i
think
some of these guys need to stop
apologizing i think we need to realize
that a guy like this
he has a playbook that he used he went
and bought washington post to control
his narrative
that's his youtube that's his twitter
that's his new york times that's says
l.a times that's his
you know uh time magazine that mark
benninghoff bought from salesforce
and he's delivering his message through
that so let me circle right let me
circle this back to you and then
we'll do this so he said that he thought
that bezos wants to live forever i said
he wants to kind of take over
you know space in the world what do you
think bezos's long-term plan is you
showed the example of the clock
is it legacy is it living forever what
do you actually think it is yeah i don't
know i
i the only thing that i can think about
is power it's the only thing i can think
about is power
and i think there's a part of them i
think there's a part of them and this is
this is going to be pretty
difficult so go to certain people who
grew up
not getting a lot of attention yeah go
to a certain group of people that didn't
have girlfriends in high school or
didn't get a lot of attention they
didn't get a lot of play
they were kind of boring and then later
on give them a lot of money and power
what happened silicon valley exactly
silicon valley exactly they want to go
back and
you know make up for the 16th seven
because for a long time
what they didn't do because they didn't
get the attention now it's like coming
like this from all over
dude let me make one quick point yeah
you brought up who's
helping him with his messaging who's
helping him business messaging
so let me just say one thing i'll turn
it over he says i want to thank all the
amazon employees and every amazon
customer because you guys
paid for all this all he needed to do
was substitute one word
paid for all this when you're the
richest man in the world stop using the
word pay
just say you guys enabled this you guys
made this happen
whatever this is this is giving you
credit rather than you paid for all this
i'll take so here here's my point jeff
bezos
was a freaking nerd in high school
long time ago though man okay but still
you've seen
you've seen the picture of him and
amazon.com
and he's just in his library and he's
half bald and he hasn't shaved his head
yet and he's like
i think i'm going to start with a
bookstore like dude the guy was a
full-class nerd now he's the richest man
in the world he's a public figure
like you said his pretty good looking
guy today like but wait a minute no no
no i'm not talking with what he's got
he's working with what he's got he's
banging lorraine sanchez
he's made it work um he's doing his
thing
respect but the point is he's making up
for lost time
yeah but you know how they say um
you give you give someone money and they
don't change it exposes who they really
really are
yeah so if you give a good man money
he'll do good things you give a bad man
money he'll still continue bad things
i think he's just a full-on nerd who's
now got a hundred billion dollars
and he's doing you know his thing his
messaging is horrible two points on that
all right first point
is i agree with you i agree with pat the
repentant rich are the worst
human beings on planet earth nobody
wants to hear you complain and nobody
wants to hear i was a part in this
i wasn't if he came out and he was like
they were like why did you go to outer
space and he was like because i could
i've been like this is the
coolest dude on earth basement that's
because i
cause it was there what do you mean
cause it was there
and i wanted to be there and i'd be like
yo bezos this guy gets it bro
like stop complaining about everything
when you're rich buy a couple jet skis
and be like ah this is dope you should
try this
like you know what i'm saying like yo go
get another job this is wow
that's what i want to see out of the
rich because if the rich keep crying
what's the point of any of this man like
what is the point jump off a bridge like
if prince harry can't be happy married
to a freaking model i'm a preacher
everything's hard
dude come on man oh you're talking about
the even meghan markle
it's insane get a fast car and drive and
be like
this is pretty fun after all i look
being wealthy dude that's what i want to
see
number two the revenge of the nerds is a
real thing
everybody in silicon valley is running
the world right now they're running the
narrative and i wasn't a movie that was
a documentary that's a gadget
bro it's all everybody that runs our
life right now looks good we pull up a
picture of ogre from revenge of the
nerds ogre
yeah gerard you could star as ogre in
the next revenge of the nerf yeah i'm
ready for it let's get those nerds
yeah paint number one
by the way that movie would be cancel
cultured in them can you imagine that or
porky's
there's gerard let's get those nerds
[Laughter]
ivy leaguers have ruined everything i
love
oh my gosh okay all right
okay there it is yeah exactly gerard
response
okay all right let's go to uh we'll
we'll see by the way if you're listening
to this
and you fired up yourself if you listen
to this seriously if you're listening to
this
if if you don't think he has any other
major
ambitions like you're like okay i think
he just wants to be you know whatever
comment below let us know what you think
bezos's major ambitions are so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye